[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up Prof
hello Walter I'm Martin yeah so let's
continue with very important subjects
yes and uh before we do that we can open
with the word of prayer absolutely
essential
Our Father in Heaven it's a privilege to
be here again and thank you for giving
us the privilege and the opportunity
will you guide our discussion in this
episode and also Enlighten the minds of
the viewers and ours and let us see what
you want us to understand in this
discussion in Jesus name amen amen
now Martin we don't want that people
think we are laboring the subject
but it is a very important aspect
of God's Church
throughout the ages yes
and throughout the ages it has always
been controversial
and there's always been a great deal of
opposition
because you know when you speak about
the spirit of Prophecy within a church
or within God amongst God's people
how do you know
well you test the spirits that's it
but if the spirit is saying something
that is contrary to your Fallen nature
and you don't want to give it up it is
very
likely that you will
give some opposition
or disclaim and say no no no this this
cannot be from God this is something
else exactly you can get a little bit
jealous sometimes yes
and so this is a very important subject
and
you know the Bible says if you listen to
the prophets you will be established
yeah
and you have to believe them
but it's hard to believe something if
it's contrary to your way of thinking
not just this week again I had a call
from someone
who said I don't want to hear anything
about that especially not you know then
they bring the gender issue
and it's so ridiculous really because if
you study your Bible that is not the
issue at all
you see the problem is not one time were
the people that the prophet was sent to
happy with the prophet no they were
always unhappy because the prophet you
know touched their personal lives
and rebuked whatever they were doing
and they were really sincere in what
they were doing but they were
unfortunately very sincerely wrong
foreign
but we can quickly pull that through to
the end yes at when the people will be
thinking that doing God a favor in
getting rid of the real people that are
trying to do what is wrong but it's
right okay so this is very very
important in terms of understanding the
Dynamics of how God works within the
church now we did the Bible study
in the last one
and people will still say yes but
it's in addition to
and that's basically a cult if you are
relying on information outside of
scriptures that's why most people want
to put the label of cult unto The
Seventh-Day Adventist Church correct so
we need to understand
the purpose of the spirit of Prophecy so
we need to understand what what is it
why
and for when
exactly
and if we have though the answers to
those questions
then it's undeniable that it should go
through and uplift the church yes and
and I think we must we must seriously
talk about this theme
because it will affect everything
we will continue to look at signs of the
times and what's happening historically
and politically and religiously that's a
very important aspect
but if the heart and the mind is not in
tune with the mind of God
then we are running on Parallel tracks
unfortunately and then I mean if you
take it in normal
example if you've got a horse pulling
this way and a horse pulling this way
you're not gonna go anywhere you're not
gonna go anywhere so let's have a look
at it and see what we can glean from
this
well here's a quote
God is waiting for men and women to
awake to their responsibilities
he is waiting for them to link
themselves with him let them Mark the
signal of advance and no longer be
laggards in working out the will of the
Lord
do we realize how large a number in the
world are watching our movements
it's an interesting question
from quarters where we least expect will
come voices urging us forward in the
work of giving to the world the last
message of Mercy
ministers and people wake up
be quick to recognize and seize every
opportunity and Advantage offered in the
Turning of the wheel of Providence
now before I continue There
I've had situations like that
I've heard people from government
I've had people from the military
I've had high offices from the police
I've even had people from the Secret
Service
and I even had a Jesuit
come to me during the meetings when
there was a gap
and tell me
that I'm being watched yeah
then I would say
is that a warning or is that yeah an
encouragement what must I say yeah
and they would say carry on do what you
are doing
and you wouldn't expect it right
now even the first part the world are
watching
um they're watching you add that time
when Mark Woodman
pitched up and come came to stay with
you to see if what you say you how you
live your health style he wanted to
check whether this was a fraudulent
issue or not
well that was another interesting one
anyway let's continue God and Christ and
the Heavenly angels are working with
intense activity to hold in check the
fierceness of Satan's Wrath
that God's plan may not be thwarted now
remember the devil was Wrath with a
woman
and went to make war with a remnant of a
seed and then it had the two criteria
right we spoke about that last time
so God lives and Reigns he is conducting
the Affairs of the universe let his
soldiers move forward to Victory
Let There Be Perfect unity in the ranks
we've had that so many times can we have
perfect Unity if we don't see eye to eye
no
it's very important what's going to
bring us into the perfect unit there has
to be something that there's Unity found
around
so let them press the battle to the
gates as a mighty conqueror the Lord
will work for them
let the gospel message ring through our
churches summoning them to Universal
action
that the members of the church have
increased Faith gaining Zeal from their
unseen Heavenly allies
from a knowledge of their exhaustless
resources from the greatness of the
Enterprise in which they are engaged and
from the power of their leader that's
quite a list though Martin
[Music]
so we need to increase in faith we need
to have Zeal from The Unseen
we need to recognize we have Heavenly
allies we're not alone in this fight
they have exhaustless resources
and the greatness of the Enterprise must
impress us and we must know that we have
a leader there is a column of fire and a
column of cloud in front of us and
behind us right
a leader that won't disappoint those who
place themselves under God's control to
be led and guided by him will catch the
steady thread of the events ordained by
him to take place so we need to look at
what's happening in the political the
religious sphere Etc
inspired by the spirit of him who gave
his life for the life of the world
they will no longer stand still in
impotency
pointing to what they cannot do putting
on the armor of Heaven they will go
forth forth to Warfare willing to do and
Dare for God knowing that his
omnipotence will supply their need
but this sounds like uh people with a
mission
definitely that's you have an agenda
yeah it's like a
a wall March yes
it's it's a mission it's we this is
something we have to accomplish
and how we're going to achieve that this
is what is so lacking in God's church
today
so let's talk about the spirit of
Prophecy
and the writings
what are they not
because people always say I have the
Bible and that's all I need
well if you have the Bible and that's
all you need then why are there
thousands of Protestant denominations
that say they have the Bible and that's
all that they need and none of them see
eye to eye yeah
except when they come together on points
that they do agree on
and put everything else aside yes
then that they can stand and say the
Bible in the Bible alone but when it
comes to these difficult ones that they
don't want to see eye and eye what do
they do then exactly good question
so they are not to take the place of the
Bible
so here's an extract from a testimony
published in 1876 Brother Jay
would confuse the Mind by seeking to
make it appear that the light God has
given through the testimonies
is in addition to the word of God but in
this he presents the matter in a false
light
God has seen fit in this manner to bring
the minds of his people to his word to
give them a clearer understanding of it
the word of God is sufficient to
Enlighten the most beclouded mind
and may be understood by those who have
any desire to understand it
but
notwithstanding all this some who
profess to make the word of God their
study are found living in direct
opposition to its plainest teachings
is that a fact or not it's a fact it's a
fact plain teachings no the Bible says
Jesus says if you love me keep my
commandment pain teaching and they say
no no in actual fact I've even heard
that you're sinning if you keep the
command yeah yeah even Jesus sinned by
breaking the Sabbath all this type of
nonsense that you get to right
than to leave men and women without
excuse God gives plain and pointed
testimonies bringing them back to the
word
that they have neglected to follow
the word of God abounds in general
principles for the formation of correct
habits of living and the testimonies
General and personal
have been calculated to call their
attention more especially to these
principles
all right so the word of God is the norm
in the standard
now let's take a commandment like
Thou shalt not commit adultery
then people think well that pretends
only to what happens in the marriage
relationship right
but if you read a little bit further in
the laws that you get in the first five
books of the Bible
there's a whole chapter
on what constitutes
transgression of the seventh commandment
it has everything in it from the worst
to the smallest detail
and it's all part of the seventh
commandment that's the explanation of it
and if people still don't get it then
what about some testimonies exactly
because actually
like we've mentioned in the previous
episode
what this is a testimony already the
Bible is a testimony and every time God
wants to make it more understandable
that's why he also went through the
Covenant yes there was a the government
was like this this not new covenants
it's just a new way of in trying to show
you the original correct now let's take
another very simple example
councils on diets and Foods fruits nuts
grains and vegetables that's your diet
right
don't have fat and grease and don't eat
meat and animal products they're not
safe in the last days is that what she
basically writes yes
is anybody happy with that no nobody
all right they say no the Bible talks
about clean and unclean meat so that
that should be fine all right let's just
take one verse in the Bible I give you
every I give you every seed bearing
plant and every tree with fruit on it
and it shall be yours for food that's
the original design for the body is
there anything about eggs in there is
there anything about going to the mudder
of a cow and asking her for
for nutrients no that's it right
then sin came into the world and he said
as I gave you every seed bearing plant
etc etc now I give you this plants of
the field is there anything about meat
there yeah well I just stop there
so if we go to the spirit of Prophecy
and it says that fruits grants nuts and
vegetables
is the best of food is that in harmony
with scripture exactly okay if it says
meat should not be included is that in
harmony no not with the original plan
not from the beginning no okay
all right so then God gave directions
about what kind of animals they were
allowed to eat and what they were not
allowed to eat
that was after the flood right
well did Noah already know what clean
and unclean was yes yes well he
certainly did know because he had seven
pairs of clean
and one pair of unclean
and he had to sacrifice which ones
the clean the clean so if it only had
one pair that would have been it has
been gone right
all right so
did God when he took them out of Egypt
put them on a plot-based diet
did they crave flesh meat
they did right exactly what the Bible
says okay was he pleased with him no all
right so what's the big deal if we have
an expansion on it that says why and
wherefore and very plainly explains that
what the diet is
I for example was
rebellious against that
but when I started testing it in the lab
I had to come to the conclusion that the
only fool in the story was me
unfortunately when you have to do with
anything the Bible says
and if you get a book like the spirit of
prophecy books that
supported or is in line with it yes and
you kick against it then you are going
to be shown to be a fool out of it
eventually did God give a law from Mount
Sinai
well yes they ask people to obey it yes
so if the spirit of Prophecy says why
don't you obey it isn't that in harmony
with God's word
all right so let's just leave it there I
think it's important what the way you
just portrayed how actually plain and
easy it can be yes it's like the Bible
into it you so when the when the
Pharisees argued with Jesus about
divorce issues ETC because you know
divorce was now permissible just write
the little scribble a little note and
off she goes right
he said it was not so in the beginning
so
as it was in the beginning is obviously
how God wanted it right
so how's it going to be in the end isn't
it going to in the end have to be like
it was in the beginning that's where
what's what's he logical about that all
right let's continue
the Lord designs to warn you to reprove
to counsel through the testimonies given
and to impress your minds with the
importance of the truth of his word
the written testimonies are not to give
new light but to impress vividly upon
the heart the truths of inspiration
already revealed
so what are they not they're not in
addition to the Bible all right so
Martin if this is very plain writing as
to what the intention is
there will be some that say well then we
don't need it that's it she says no new
light we don't we don't need anything
else so why are you constantly using the
spirit of Prophecy the whole time
correct
all right let's continue with the story
God has in that word promised to give
Visions in the last days
not for a new rule of Faith but for the
comfort of his people and to correct
those who ER from Bible truth thus God
dealt with Peter when he was about to
send him to preach to the Gentiles
okay
must be tested by the Bible the spirit
was not given nor can it ever be
bestowed to supersede the Bible
for the scriptures explicitly state that
the word of God is the standard by which
all teaching and experience must be
tested Isaiah declares to the law and to
the testimony if they speak not
according to this word it is because
there is no light in them
so I think that makes it quite plain
from the writings themselves
that they're not in addition to the
Bible
but they make plain which people love to
make obscure that's it
the problem is a lot of people
don't believe that they are in harmony
with the Bible they say yes but this
that she says here is not in the Bible
but if you study it through you will
come to a different conclusion but
that's where the problem comes in
that's why we have to do what they are
all right so we now know what they're
not
so the question is then what are they
so what they are
I recommend you dear reader the word of
God as the rule of your faith and
practice
by that word we are to be judged God has
in that word promised to give Visions in
the last days
not for a new rule of Faith but for the
comfort of his people and to correct
those who are from Bible truth
is that pretty plain
so why but let's just put it like this
again we've mentioned it many times why
did God send a prophet every time to
Israel to get them back on the right
path because they were they were airing
from the way over there right
here's another one from the review and
Herald
1856 at our last conference at Battle
Creek in November God wrought for us
the minds of the Servants of God were
exercised as to the gifts of the church
and if God's frown had been brought upon
his people because the gifts had been
slighted and neglected there was a
pleasing prospect that he smiles would
again be upon us and he would graciously
and mercifully revive the gifts again
and they would live in the church to
encourage the desponding and fainting
soul and to correct and reprove the
earring
sir Martin
if you're going to read it what are you
going to find you're going to find
correction
and you're going to find reproof
and you're going to find encouragement
depending how you want to read it right
oh that's so important
you can read it as if it's a stick
hitting you the whole time yes or you
can read it and say God what do you want
me to do to live better and please you
yes
now in the beginning when I first
discovered all of these things I have I
had a somewhat rebellious nature
and had to learn uh sometimes the hard
way
that uh you know God's way is the best
way that's it my wife on the other hand
she couldn't wait to read it to see what
was wrong that's what she had to do
correct she had a much better attitude
than I had but I think that's the the
biggest problem today
we must all have that attitude that your
wife had yes but do you realize that I
then could get irritated even with my
poor wife yeah yeah especially then
because now she's coming to you I don't
think we must do this what
where does it stand in the Bible
exactly so this is very interesting so
Martin
that's what they are they are there to
encourage to correct and to reprove
and not many people can handle reproof
but
if you want to come into harmony
with God's word
then you have to accept reproof I was
thinking did Jesus reproof yes but
people then say today but yes you must
just show the love of Jesus
so they missed us through that love that
was love exactly the people have a
misunderstanding and we've done a whole
episode of what love is I remember one
quote which says more or less something
like this
the sheer effort it takes to get back is
the greatest evidence of how far we have
fallen
so what are they
God has seen fit in this manner to bring
the minds of his people to his word
to give them a clearer understanding of
it is that important
I think especially now with every wind
of Doctrine blowing everywhere now in
the 1500s
didn't the reformers study the Bible
Daniel and Revelation and didn't they
have very clear views on Daniel 7 and
Revelation 13 as to who the Beast was
yes
that too because that's what was
bringing in in harmony with the original
Church all right so now you can read all
of those works of the reformers and you
can see that
by the time this this Spirit of Prophecy
was written those things had been
forgotten yep again they had been swept
under the rug and
that people had to be reminded
and brought back to you know where we
should be exactly various denominations
had discovered many things
the methodists had discovered Temperance
and introduced The Temperance movements
but the rest had forgotten it they were
on moonshine
some doctrines came out of that yeah
very interesting Doctrine okay so a
clearer understanding of God's word
and to have a clear understanding of
God's word you need a clear mind and to
have a clear mind you need a clear
coming body and a clean stomach
the Lord designs to warn you to reprove
to counsel through the testimonies given
and to impress your mind with the
importance of the truth of his word that
seems to be a central issue
the written testimonies are not to give
new light but to impress vividly upon
the heart the truths of the inspiration
already revealed
now we've read that before but let's
continue with it
man's duty to God and to his fellow man
has been distinctly specified in God's
word
yet but few of you are obedient to the
light given additional truths are not
brought out but God has through the
testimonies simplified the great truths
already given
and in his own chosen way brought them
before the people to awaken and impress
the mind with them
that all may be left without excuse
so I don't if what I tell you plainly
there's that and the other then
basically you're without excuse if you
ignore it right
well 100 and you see this is where also
if you read this when it comes that that
is the great light
and the little light just makes it shine
brighter and you can understand it
better that's another thing that's
misconstrued the greater light and the
little light so the little light well
then that's not so important it sounds
unimportant but if it is to make
understandable the greater light then it
is of great significance
because the great light
leads to much confusion when you distort
it oh for sure we can see that in the
world can't we
all right in ancient times God spoke to
Men by the mouth of prophets and
apostles in these days he speaks to them
by the testimonies of the spirit
there was never a time when God
instructed his people more earnestly
than he instructs them now concerning
his will
and the course that he would have them
pursue never a Time
more earnestly
isn't it important that the last message
of warning to the world
Goes Forth from an uncorrupted Source oh
of course otherwise you get mixed
messages right and how did they not
blur the truth with all those versions
out there yes so there are many aspects
as to what constitutes the word
you know the Romans Catholics say You
must include the Apocrypha
and then they say no we must rather use
these manuscripts or those manuscripts
or you know these we've dug up in the
desert sand where God Faithfully hid
them so that nobody could know the truth
for thousands of years except us but
nonsense anyway
so purpose of the testimonies then to
leave men and women without excuse
God gives plain and pointed testimony
he's bringing them back to the word
that they have neglected to follow
the word of God abounds in general
principles for the formation of correct
habits of living
and the testimonies General and personal
have been calculated to call their
attention more specifically to these
principles now we've read this one
before
in a in another format
but that's the basis of it now if you go
back to Old Testament times
was the word lust the law yeah was it
lost in the temple yes either in the
temple in the temple did they thoroughly
have to clean house to find it yeah
and when they found it and they brought
it to the king didn't the king dare his
clothes he was shocked that our father
had drifted
but if they could lose it when they had
the temple service when they had the
priesthood when they had all the ritual
there
if they could lose it then
can't Humanity lose it today definitely
all right so if you if you look at what
humanity is doing even in the legal
system
where they are making laws which are so
blatantly contrary to the word of God
and then arguing that it is in harmony
with the word of God it boggles the mind
right you see the problem is
they say it's in harmony with the Bible
but they can't prove it they never bring
scripture No that's a big problem these
days
oh yeah yeah exactly you've got lots of
preachers telling you ah but the Bible
says this and this and this we've shown
many of these sermons
how many times do you read the full
context and actually do a Bible study
there we are not under the law
Bible says clearly we are not under the
law do it thereby make void the law God
forbid they don't read that one no no we
establish
yeah all right here's another quote when
the power of God testifies as to what is
truth
that truth is to stand forever
as truth
so when the Bible defines something as
truth that's truth yeah
and if the spirit of Prophecy confirms
what the Bible has said it cannot change
it
so no after suppositions contrary to the
light God has given are to be
entertained men will arise with
interpretations of scripture which are
to them truth but which are not truth
the truth for this time God has given us
as a foundation for our faith he himself
has taught us what is truth
one will arise and still another with
new light which contradicts the light
that God has given under the
demonstration of the Holy Spirit
a few are still alive will pass through
the experience gained in the
establishment of this truth
so how did they do that by Bible study
right
and when they could go no further
because they had all of these
denominational ideas the spirit of
Prophecy showed the path and suddenly it
became plain
so God has graciously spared the lives
to repeat and repeat till the close of
their lives they experience through
which they passed even as did John the
Apostle to the very close of his life
and the standard bearers who have fallen
in death are to speak through the
reprinting of their writings I'm
instructed
that thus their voices are to be heard
they are to Bear their testimony as to
what constitutes Truth for this time
now in our last episode we actually did
that we let Uriah Smith speak right
and we should do it far more and
again
the same if we let them speak they still
must be in harmony with the Bible
correct now our pioneers
at the risk of being contentious Martin
may I you may may I yes did they believe
in the cosmic week yes
do our modern theologians believe in the
cosmic week no did the spirit of
Prophecy give enough evidence that she
was in harmony with the cosmic week yes
but
if I have to choose between the modern
theologians and what the pioneers and
the spirit of Prophecy says
I'm afraid
I don't want to finish my sins
a wealth of moral influence has been
brought to us in the last half century
through his holy spirit the voice of God
has come to us continually in warning
and instruction to confirm the faith of
the Believers in the spirit of Prophecy
a wealth of moral influence
is the World experience a wealth of
immoral influence terrible all right how
do you stand against it with the moral
side and the truth okay so you have to
fight error with truth that's it so if
the church
loses its moral compass
and cannot discern what is the will of
God and what is not the will of God
let's take gender issues for example
let's take
lgbtq we might as well say the whole
alphabet you know a b c d e f g h i j k
l m n o p because that's the way they're
going right for what is permissible
other churches even within our own ranks
who are jumping onto that worldly
bandwagon yeah
Martin have we lost our moral campus yes
we have okay why is that because they
neglect the spirit of Prophecy The
Testament and do they distort the word
of God yes so that that what the word of
God says is what the word of God did not
say well you can actually get scary
things that there's people that well
I've heard ask
uh but what about this same sex marriage
or relationships because there's
probably examples of it in the Bible
like for instance Naomi and and Ruth is
it yes that's how they use that too or
David and Jonathan yeah they will use
verses like that now if they had a
relationship Naomi and Ruth why would
Naomi encourage her to go to Boaz well
it's so it's so distorted it's
unbelievable but it shows you that's
what happens when you lose your moral
compass correct
so we have a mouth wealth of moral
influence and that has been brought to
us
through his holy spirit the voice of God
has come to us continually in warning
and instruction to confirm the faith of
the Believers in the spirit of Prophecy
so you can read the Bible you can
distort it as we saw but when you read
the spirit of Prophecy you can't because
it's plain it's very plain it's very
direct
so
well then you must put it aside right
yeah you have to discard it you have all
put it in a lesser
prominent place for instance the whole
time we're reading this I can hear
people say yeah but this was written for
200 years back
or if you take uh
issues of sexuality
it is so plainly written what the
relationship should be between a man and
a woman
what
your control of your sexuality should be
there is no room for for distorting
anything in the spirit of Prophecy so
the only thing that you can do if you
don't agree with it is put it aside
so repeatedly the word has come write
the things that I have given you to
confirm the faith of my people in the
position they have taken
time and trial have not made void the
instruction given but through years of
suffering and self-sacrifice have
established the truth of the testimony
given
the instruction that was given in the
early days of the message is to be held
as safe instruction to follow in these
its closing days can you therefore say
this was 19th century literature no no
of course then the closing days must
have been gone already okay those who
are indifferent to this light and
instruction must not expect to escape
the snares which we have been plainly
told will cause the rejectors of the
light to stumble and fall to be snared
and to be taken but there are many in
this church
that that will be taken in these stairs
and will stumble in fact I have stumbled
already
and if they don't watch it they won't be
able to get up that's the thing they
wake up
if we study carefully the second chapter
of Hebrews we shall learn how important
it is that we hold steadfastly to every
principle of truth that has been given
and once truth has been given
it cannot be removed no you cannot claim
I didn't know no you can't God God gave
to all the reformers the message as to
who the Beast was and what his purposes
were he gave it very plainly in the
testimonies again
and nobody in the economical circles
acknowledges enough
God designs that his people shall be a
unit that they shall see eye to eye
and be of the same mind and of the same
judgment
I had a call just this week again
from someone who says I can't be in the
church because they don't have this eye
to eye thing
they they're all over the place
there's no consistency so I cannot be
part of it so I had to explain the wheat
and the tears grow together until the
Harvest there will come as shaking
uh did ancient Israel have the truth the
answer is always yes they had the truth
did they live up to it no no
right that's how it is so that's the way
it's going to be do we have people
within the church
let's see eye to eye
that too yes they are they are there yes
all right and do they see eye to eye
because they have certain criteria that
uh lead them to ci2i yes
they read they study
and they
acknowledge that there is a gift in the
church and didn't Paul say I wish you
were all like me
and didn't Paul say and if there are
some things which you see differently
God will lead you to that too
because he knew what the truth was
because he got it prophetically exactly
God showed it to him so if you can't see
it that way like exactly Paul said then
pray read and get in harmony with you
have to get into harmony with the
writings of Paul you cannot change it
and if the spirit of Prophecy
is in harmony with the writings of Paul
you better get in tune with the spirit
of Prophecy too the prayer of Christ was
that his disciples may be one as he was
one with the father
Martin
at the Last Supper
were they all won no no
I risked my case
all right
at Pentecost we're the old one yes
okay neither pray I for these alone but
for them also which Shall Believe on me
through their word
that they all may be one as thou father
ought in me and I indeed that they also
may be one in US
that the world may believe that thou
sent me and the glory which thou gavest
me I have given them that there may be
one even as we are one i in them and
thou in me that they may be made perfect
in one that the world may know that thou
sent me and has loved them as thou has
loved me is it essential that we can
become one yes one mindset
they're trying to become one yes but in
the wrong
that's a peace and safety ecumenism and
that's the one that God says leads to
destruction all right
now there are so many people that say
you know I don't want this and I don't
need anything in addition we've spoken
about that before
and one of the things that you have to
look at in a prophet is do they live up
to what they are
representing that's it
and is there life in harmony with their
teaching
now it's always good to look at what the
outside world has to say and we can
bring many quotes you know she had no
filthy Luca she was living the life of
an honorable person Etc and you also got
the ex the
doctors that weren't related to the
church that were brought into
acknowledge that even the biblical
criteria for
um to be a prophet was acknowledged by
external people as well yes
so this is a very interesting quote
which uh I think really deserves to be
read again
this is a quote from the non-adventist
sources of her day and this one comes
from American biographical history of
eminent and self-made men of the state
of Michigan third Congressional District
page 108 so this is a secular source
that is writing about Ellen G white
and it says as a speaker Mrs White is
one of the most successful of the few
ladies who have become noteworthy as
lecturers in this country
during the last 20 years constant use
has so strengthened her vocal organs
as to give her voice a rare depth and
power a modern
my experience is that constant use wears
out the voice exactly well if you take
yourself how did you struggle when you
add all those speaking appointments all
that the voice would go it would go but
here was something very different
well I must also just bring in sometimes
you didn't have a voice but you got a
voice when you went on to speak yes and
you can practice your voice you can
speak correctly and you can learn all of
these things but there was something
very different about Ellen G white
let's read on her clearness and strength
of articulation are so great
that when speaking in the open air she
has frequently been distinctly heard at
the distance of a mile
that's incredible yeah
when speaking in the open air she has
been hurt for a distance of a mile a
language though simple is always
forcible
when inspired with her subject she's
often marvelously eloquent
holding the largest audience's
Spellbound for hours without a sign of
impatience or weariness
now what this was a frail woman who was
relatively short and sickly sickly
now this is also done there were no
speakers no amplifiers
the subject matter of a discourses is
always of a practical character
bearing chiefly on the Fireside duties
the religious education of children
Temperance and Kindred topics
on Revival occasions she's always the
most effective speaker she has
frequently spoken to immense audiences
in large cities on her favorite themes
and has always been received with great
favor
on one occasion in Massachusetts 20
000 persons listened to her with close
attention for more than an hour Martin
speaking to 20 000 people
in open air because there's no Hall
that's going to take 20 000 people
and being heard a mile away is that
miraculous I think it is definitely
from God and well that that help is from
God to to be able to Only God can do
that so the voice rises above and often
she had to speak
over opposition yes and people screaming
and her voice would rise and go over all
of them and everybody could plainly hear
what she was saying in spite of opposing
noises
and then of course you have many many
quotes on her character
and her life
Etc but this is just one to show that
this is something Supernatural
and it's either from God or it's from
the Devil and there's one way to find
out is it an harmony with the word
that's it so Martin
if it is from God
and surely there are consequences to
rejecting it well let me let's just
backtrack to that surely if it's from
God
I don't know what more we can do to try
and really get people
to understand that it is from God
I don't know the proof of the pudding is
in the reading in the reading the only
way you can if you if you want to argue
against it you haven't read you haven't
read it that's for sure
all right what are the consequences
the Pharisees said one to another if we
had lived in the days of our fathers we
would not have United with them in
shedding the blood of God's servants
at the same time they were planning to
take the life of his son this should
open our eyes to the power of Satan to
deceive the mind that turns from the
light of Truth
many Wonder at the blindness of the Jews
in rejecting Christ and we lived in his
day they declare we would never have
been partakers in the guilt of those who
rejected the savior
but when obedience to God requires
self-denial and humiliation these very
persons refuse obedience
they manifest The Same Spirit as did the
Pharisees
you take the persecution in the Middle
Ages God was pointing to his word
they were reading the word
and the result was that they were
tortured and persecuted to death
that's it same thing and if you want to
take it a step further then some of the
people that reformed and got people out
of that also started persecuting some
other people so they were also not doing
what the Bible is saying as soon as
somebody had new light they got stuck in
their old light
so in many cases the testimonies are
fully received the sin and Indulgence
broken off and Reformation that once
commences in harmony with the light God
has given
in other infant instances sinful
indulgences are cherished the
testimonies are rejected and many
excuses which are untrue are offered to
others as the reason for refusing to
receive them the true reason is not
given it is a lack of moral courage a
will strengthened and controlled by the
spirit of God to renounce hurtful habits
bottom line
it is Satan's plan to weaken the faith
of God's people in the testimonies Satan
knows how to make his attacks he works
upon the minds to excite jealousy
dissatisfaction towards those at the
head of the work
the gifts are then questioned then of
course they have but little weight and
instruction given through vision is
disregarded next follow skepticism in
regard to vital points of our faith the
pillars of our position then doubt as to
the holy scriptures and then the
downward march to Perdition
when the testimonies which were once
believed or doubted and given up Satan
knows that the deceived ones will not
stop at this he redoubles his efforts
till he launches them in open Rebellion
which becomes incurable and ends in
destruction
there's a sad State of Affairs
sad State of Affairs it continues
by giving place to doubt and unbelief in
regard to the work of God and by
cherishing feelings of distrust and
cruel jealousies they are preparing
themselves for complete deception
they rise up with better feelings
against the ones who dare to speak of
their errors and reprove their sins it
is not alone those who openly reject the
testimonies or cherish doubt concerning
them that are in Dangerous Ground to
disregard light is to reject it
that's a scary one there Martin
I wonder if you can put on there to
postpone light
is to reject it the Lord is still giving
me time to do this that and the other if
you know something is wrong
you know click on it when they came to
pharaoh and said when shall I ask the
Lord to remove this he said tomorrow
yeah he wanted to live another boat with
the plague
why not now
if you lose confidence in the
testimonies you will drift away from
Bible truth Martin that's a serious one
I've been fearful that many would take a
questioning doubting position and in my
distress for your souls I would warn you
how many will heed the warning
[Music]
many who have backslidden from truth
assigned as a reason for their course
that they have not faith in the
testimonies
the question now is will they yield
their Idol which God condemns or will
they continue in their wrong course of
indulgence and reject the light God has
given them reproving the very things in
which they Delight
the question to be settled with them is
shall I deny myself and receive as of
God the testimonies which reprove my
sins
or shall I reject the testimonies
because they reprove my sins
Martin
I wonder how many people
like this one
I don't think they read it
I think they you see that the thing is
when you know something
and for instance if you know a book is
going to tell you your faults How likely
if you don't have the attitude that you
said your wife had but you're more
likely at the attitude that you used to
have are you going to pick up that book
and read it
you see I picked up Desire of Ages oh
yes and I read that
and I was a changed man yeah because
that's beautiful my wife picked up
councils sometimes some food
so you see but both is written in the
same
instructed by the same loving God
correct now she would have probably
greatly benefited from Desire of Ages as
I did
but I couldn't do it that way around so
God said you read that one you must
first she reads that one and then she
will irritate you to the point where you
say give me that book because the more
you you read the one to see God's
character in Desire of Ages the more
you're struggling to see how can I how
can he then get this book to be written
and that's what like you mentioned
Martin Luther yes Where Mercy and
Justice meet you that's about the same
with this so God and His Mercy said read
Desire of Ages from the same author and
then counsels on diets and food
and then I would say okay all right
let's try this
all right neglect of the testimonies it
is not alone those who openly reject the
testimonies or who cherish doubt
concerning them that are in Dangerous
Ground
to disregard lightness to reject it some
of you in words acknowledge reproof but
you do not in the heart accepted you go
on the same as before only being less
susceptible to the influence of the
spirit of God becoming more and more
blinded having less wisdom less
self-control less moral power less Zeal
and relish for religious exercises and
unless converted you will finally yield
your hold upon God entirely you've not
made decided changes to your life when
reproof has come because you have not
seen and realized your defects of
character and the great contrast between
your life and the life of Christ
so when Christ says something and you
realize it is truth when should you
adopt it next week next month next year
immediately start working on it right
from there and ask God to help
that's the most important thing
I cannot do this by myself Lord help me
to do this surrender to him that's the
only way you're gonna overcome anything
is because he is establishing it inside
now how is it possible Martin
that if you start out resenting what you
are being told yes
that looking back to that time
I cannot understand that I could have
been so foolish
because now that which I resented is to
me a delight and that which I clung to
is to me an Abomination that's the way
it's supposed to be but now what happens
is
you this PL or downplay the importance
of this right now then you get it
exactly what she's talking about here
lays Zeal lace everything uh it gets and
then you actually develop
uh a very hard stance that I'm not gonna
change anymore I'm not gonna change
so what are your prayers amount to while
you regard iniquity in your hearts
unless you make a thorough change you
will not
not for hands become wary of reproof as
did the children of Israel and like them
you will apostatize from God that's a
very serious claim
and they eventually said wish we had
died in the wilderness
God said okay I'll let you die in the
wilderness you know
they counted them from 20 years up right
20 years up and he said not one of those
20 years up
would enter into the promised land
except Caleb and Joshua right
that means Martin
they want it in the wilderness 40 years
actually two were already gone 38 years
right yeah 38 years plus 20. that makes
it 58.
that means that many in that group
didn't enter
and must have died
before they were 58 years old
yeah
that's a serious thing now if you see
what happened then how often the plagues
struck them and when the serpent them
how many died it was thousands upon
thousands it it's all the rebellious
ones yes because Joshua and Caleb they
were old
yeah and they went in
they went in so that everybody could
have gone in you're that's a very good
some speculation that can come in there
definitely I I I if you if you read not
only that
um
testimonies but the Bible version of
this it makes sense exactly what you say
if you take it back to what did God do
they lusted for these things and he gave
it to them and what happened while it
was still between their teeth yeah so
the wasting disease into their souls so
obviously for these 40 years they were
still rebellious all of a sudden say oh
okay great I'm Gonna Change now yes well
because none of them went in that's
better scary yeah
many are going directly contrary to the
light which God has given to his people
because they do not read the books which
contain the light and knowledge and in
cautions reproofs and warnings
the cares of the world the love of
fashion the lack of religion have turned
the attention from the light Gods has so
graciously given while books and
periodicals containing error are
traveling all over the country
I was in a bookstore on the North
American continent once
and it was an Adventist bookstore
and every single book of every wind of
Doctrine was displayed out there books
about you know Rick Warren and folks and
all of these books were displayed
and I was looking around and I was
looking for a particular volume of the
spirit of Prophecy
nowhere to be found
so I went to the person that was in
charge there
and I said
where can I find this and that oh oh at
the shelf on the back at the back
so I went to the back and right there
hidden in the back there were a couple
of spirit of prophecy books very sparse
of course the one that I was looking for
was not there at all
and I thought I'm gonna leave it like
this so I'm gonna say that something so
I came out from behind this hidden
bookstore bookshelf
and I said you know I thought those were
the leaves of autumn yeah so what are
all these leaves standing out here
and they were not very pleased with me
at all but that's true they don't read
them it's so sad you know it's
it's with both the Bible that version if
you go to look for it you have to search
for it in a bookstore and I was in in
the continent of Europe
at one of our colleges
in one of the Germanic languages
and they were boasting at the extent of
their Library
and I went through the library with them
and they showed me their library and
they were very proud because it was
mainly of that one language authors
and I said you know this library is very
nice but it's very one-sided you know
I'm really not too interested in what
Carl Bart had to say or any one of these
you know where are your other books
and they showed me a little shelf
size with a couple of books I don't know
I thought to myself you know what you
have a lot of worldly knowledge but
virtually zero wisdom in this Library
this is maybe you know this is maybe a
useless comparison but
when you want to know the truth and it's
always obscured here
when you went to that place the occult
side
you they also had the good books Eden
the blavatsky ones yes so you Bailey and
everything oh so you arrived then he
brings the real ones it's the same with
with the truth it seems it's hidden
everywhere all the time always hidden
all right so they don't want to read the
books the cares of the world the love of
fashion the lack of religion
have turned the attention from the light
of God has so graciously given while
books and periodicals containing error
are traveling all over the country
skepticism infidelity or increasing
everywhere light so precious coming from
the Throne of God is hit under a bushel
God will make his people responsible for
this neglect
an account must be rendered to him for
every ray of light he has let shine upon
our pathway whether it has been improved
to our advancement in Divine things
or rejected because it was more
agreeable to follow inclination
and I'm afraid we've had many of these
things happening within our eggs
sir Martin the importance of the spirit
of Prophecy we saw what it is not
it's not there to take you away from the
Bible it's not in addition to the Bible
it's to make prominent the truth that
I've already been revealed
we saw what it is
it's therefore
bringing you back to the word of God for
reproof for encouragement
Etc
now that messenger that wrote all of
those things
that spoke with that voice to twenty
thousand people a voice reaching more
than a mile away
that had all the manifestation and we've
dealt with that before of a prophet of
God according to the Bible
that Prophet is dead
will there be another one
well let's read will there be another
messenger
abundant light has been given to our
people in these last days
whether or not my life is spared my
writings will constantly speak and their
work will go forward as long as time
shall last
my writings are kept on file in the
office and even though I should not live
these words that have been given to me
by the Lord
will still have life and will speak to
the people
but my strength is yet spared and I hope
to continue to do much useful work I may
live until the coming of the Lord but if
I should not
I trust it may be said of me blessed are
the dead which die and the Lord from
henceforth yea says the Lord that they
may rest from their labors and their
Works to follow them
and then she wrote here are my writings
when I'm gone they will testify for me
my personal conviction is there won't be
another one no I think I I agree with
you the reason being
if you start reading all of the
testimonies there is not necessary to be
anything else no everything has been
said and if people wouldn't hear what
has been said then what's the point of
doing it again right
now Jesus in his story about uh Lazarus
and the rich man
he said you have the law and the
prophets
so even if someone rises from the dead
you won't listen to him and Lazarus
actually did rise from the dead and so
did Jesus
and they didn't believe them and they
before or after absolutely correct
and then we can expect of course that
they will be maligned and attacked just
like the word of God is maligned on
attacked
Satan is constantly pressing in the
spurious to lead away from the truth the
very last deception of Satan
will be to make of non-effect the
testimony of the spirit of God
Martin that doesn't mean that you take
it away they've taken away the Bible I
have it right here exactly but they've
made it of non-effects yes
oh that is so important so it's not gone
it's still even in the church and the
church acknowledges it yes I mean now
the spirit of Prophecy they acknowledge
it but they don't do it no because they
go directly contrary to it they use it
like the preachers out there use the
Bible just to shoot what they want to
get out
so where there's no vision the people
perish Proverbs 29 18 Satan will work
ingeniously in different ways and
through different agencies to unsettle
the confidence of God's Remnant people
in the true testimony
there will be a hatred kindled against
the testimonies which is satanic Martin
that's a sign well that's what I wanted
to say just that statement proves that
she's a true Prophet must be because
that's exactly what's happening because
ah give us plavatsky ah give us Alice a
Bailey what does she have to say I wish
there would be as Keen
to do it with the spirit of prophecy
books
the workings of Satan will be to
unsettle the faith of the churches in
them for this reason
Satan cannot have so clear a track to
bring in his deceptions and bind up
souls in his delusions if the warnings
and reproofs and counsels of the spirit
of God are heeded
so what is your Shield what is your
Shield you got the Bible you put on the
armor of God and you got the testimonies
to actually help you improve that Shield
to stand against all that's not right so
now you have a church
it's like the children of Israel
they don't want to listen to the reproof
they Grumble and they Mumble they do all
kinds of things
so do we throw the baby and the bath
water away do we throw both the spirit
of Prophecy and the church away many
want to right
now what about the church
we are to be ready and waiting for the
orders of God Nations will be stirred to
their very center
support will be withdrawn from those who
claim God's only standard of
righteousness the only sure test of
character
and all who will not bow to the decree
of the national councils and obey the
national laws to exalt the Sabbath
instituted by the man of sin
to the disregard of God's holy day will
feel
not the oppressive power of potpourri
alone but of the Protestant world the
image of the Beast
Satan will work his miracles oh by the
way just that statement
is there a lot of opposition to it yeah
because there you have potpourri
and you have the Protestant world
defined as the image of the Beast
that's it isn't there a problem now with
many people if you're sitting in the
naked medical Council exactly you have
to then disregard the testimonies you
have to disregard it
Satan will work his miracles to deceive
he will set up his power as Supreme the
church may appear as about to fall
but it does not fall it remains while
the sinners in Zion will be sifted out
the top separated from the precious
wheat this is a terrible ordeal but
nevertheless it must take place none
but those who have been Overcoming By
the blood of the lamb and the word of
his testimony will be found with the
loyal and the true without spot or stain
of sin without guile in their mouths we
must be divested of our
self-righteousness
and a raid in the righteousness of
Christ Martin
you cannot do this without the spirit of
Prophecy
but here's another quote which sort of
uh confirms this let's read just the
highlighted portion
and at that time that's when the shaking
comes
The Superficial conservative class now
when she talks about conservative class
she doesn't mean conservative in the
senses we use it today
she is talking about the superficial and
those who do not want to change their
ways
they want to conserve their way yes they
keep on holding to their uh tradition
yes this class who has whose influence
has steadily the progress of
the work
will renounce their faith and take their
stand with its about enemies towards
whom their sympathies have been long
been tending okay so you've got a
communical council is that sympathy
tending correct and you start seeing it
in their light
these apostates will then manifest the
most bitter enmity doing all in their
power to oppress them align their former
brethren to excite indignation against
them this day is just before us
I believe that I think we'll we're
basically there
many will go from us giving heed to
seducing Spirits a superficial Faith
results in a superficial experience
the light given me has been very
forcible
that many would go out from us giving
heed to seducing spirits and doctrines
of devils
we gave a series inwards of Prof
doctrine of the serpent yeah
and we saw how many people and how many
denominations actually propagate
doctrines of the serpent
and if you climb onto their bandwagon
then you're going to see it in the same
light if you start pulling on the same
cart
and walking the same path this well like
we said Can two walk together unless
they agree correct if you start agreeing
this is where you're ending so the Lord
desires that every soul who claims to
believe the truth shall have an
intelligent knowledge of what is truth
false prophets will arise and will
deceive many
everything is to be shaken that can be
shaken
then does it not become everyone to
understand the reason of our faith in
place of having so many sermons there
should be more close searching of the
word of God opening the scriptures text
by text searching for the strong
evidence that sustained the fundamental
doctrines that have brought us where we
are now upon the platform of Eternal
truth now this is the Crux of the matter
here she says go and study the word to
make sure that that which we have stated
in the testimony is in harmony with the
word of God and if they are
and you reject them
you are rejecting the word of God
that's there's no play no way you can
state it
sir Martin even to the end I pray
earnestly that the work we do at this
time shall impress itself deeply on
heart and mind and soul
perplexities will increase but let us as
Believers in God encourage one another
let us not lower the standard but keep
it lifted High looking to him who is the
author and finish of our faith when in
the ninth season I am unable to sleep
I lift my heart in prayer to God and he
strengthens me and gives me the
assurance
that he is with his ministering servants
in the home field and distant lands I am
encouraged and blessed as I realize that
the god of Israel is still guiding his
people and that he will continue to be
with them even to the end
Martin
it is a burden that I have that people
understand the issue
and once they understand the issue and
enlist in the army of the Lord
they can be assured that he will
continue to be with them even to the end
to the end now
to the end
we have to know what it is because the
problem is a lot of people can say okay
but this was the end of a certain time
so that is why I think we must talk
about what is the end
what is the time of the end what is the
end time all of these the last days
there's so much confusion out there and
people say
you know this has always been
how do we know that this is now really
the end
we have to know very distinctly what
does the bible mean when it says certain
things we have to look into that one
and then we have to have a look at
what's happening in the world and we can
talk again about Davos and all kinds of
interesting things so but I believe that
this is very important as well oh
everything starts coming back and we we
will see as we go into this year we're
going to be reflecting a lot back onto
the end time and how important the
testimonies are so let's keep the
spiritual
and the political
very close to our chest yeah let's pray
Heavenly Father
you have given this church a very
special gift
and you must be heartbroken sometimes
when you see how people deal with that
special gift
open our eyes Lord that we may see
is my prayer in Jesus name amen amen
[Music]
thank you
foreign